labour is urging the government to
publish its exit strategy from the
coronavirus lockdown this week
Labour's leader secured stammer has told
Dominic Raab that while he supports the
lockdown extension the public need to
know what's coming next
for the sake of morale and hope and
handily enough as you can see Saki
Astana joins is no secure very good
morning to you and set out if you would
in just a little bit more detail exactly
what it is that you are calling upon the
government to provide you and colleagues
with yeah thank you
well first we know that the government
is going to say that lockdown has to
stay in place for a bit longer they're
right about that and I said when I took
over as leader Labour Party but the lay
part with that courage to say when the
government is right and support it we
will support that lockdown must continue
what I'm calling on the government to do
is to set out now what the exit strategy
is so in other words what will happen
next
I'm not asking for dates I do understand
that that's unrealistic and I said I
wouldn't ask the impossible but what we
need to know is what's the strategy what
are the criteria and I think there are
two main reasons we need to know that
the first is to make sure we've got the
trust of the public we're asking a lot
of the public it is really difficult
what they're going through whether
that's for health reasons economic
reasons or many many others we need to
maintain trust and I believe that
transparency is the best way to continue
that trust and a sense of hope about
what's going to happen next the second
reason is that whatever the strategy the
plans need to be in place sooner rather
than later
and give you just one a small example of
that I think it's likely that mass
testing and I mean mass testing and
tracing is likely to be part of any
strategy if we're to get mass testing in
to caution at the right time we need to
start the work on that now because as
you have seen the government struggled
with testing so far it promised 25,000
tests by the middle of April where we're
there now and they've only got 15,000
he's promised a hundred thousand by the
end of April
so I hope they achieve that but that's a
big curve but a hundred thousand is
nothing like the number we've need if we
were tamp this as part of the exit
strategy
so for public trust and planning now is
the time to set that strategy out and I
can say to the government if they do set
it out or we can test it and challenge
it and look at it but we think it's
broadly right we will then be able to
support it so there's a there's an added
advantage of taking this step now and
there will be people watching this who
welcome any opposition politician asking
questions which which frankly you know
journalists have been asking the daily
the daily briefing for quite some time
there will be others who point out that
you agree with the lockdown extension in
part I presume because that is the
advice coming from the chief medical
officer and the chief science officer
however when the chief medical officer
and the chief science officer tell you
it is too early to be discussing the
exit strategy from lock don't you
disagree well let me set out the basis
for disagreement because I said when I
took over a leader that we would be a
constructive opposition with the courage
to say we support the government where
we do but also with the courage to
challenge where we think there are
mistakes or things aren't happening
quickly enough and I said that the
purpose of that challenge would not be
to score points or just because we can
but to point out mistakes or things not
happening quickly enough so they can be
put right and that's why we focused
heavily in recent weeks on protective
equipment for the frontline
and on testing not to score a point but
just to say you're not where you need to
be you need to ramp it up
but I do think that mistakes were made
earlier in terms of the planning for
lockdown and the speed of lockdown let's
not repeat that I don't want to dwell on
the past
let's not repeat that let's actually
make the planning decisions for the
future science is really important in
this but science in the end can't tell
you what the political strategy is for
coming out of lockdown because that
involves political decisions as well as
scientific decisions part of part of
Labor's a request for this this extra
additional information appears to be
about providing some reassurance to
general public who in the manor are
following the rules to give them an idea
that there is some light at the end of
the tunnel what if there isn't a lot of
light at the end of the tunnel what if
we cannot see that end of the tunnel
just yet are we right to raise
expectations of a relaxation or even an
end to these lockdown conditions when
frankly as yet there is no empirical
data to suggest that the government
should be changing course well we do
need to reassure the public because I
think the final exit strategy can only
come with a vaccine because it's only at
that point that we can probably say we
can fully exit but we all know that a
vaccine or it is it was said that a
vaccine won't be available for 12 months
or so so the government has to answer
the question what happens in the 12
months or whatever that period is and I
think but the public's have trust in
what's going on they're going to need
answers to those questions I'm not
asking for timelines I do understand
that I accept the may have to be some
conditionality in this if X happens then
we would do the following whatever that
may be people understand that but what
they want to know is what is the
approach that you're going to take when
the curve flattens as we all desperately
hope that it does and the sooner the
better because people are putting up
with a lot I thank them I mean people
are doing amazing things in the national
interest we want them to continue to do
that but I think we can only do that if
we have their trust and this is
difficult for people particularly those
that are in overcrowded accommodation
those that are lonely with mental health
issues those that are in abusive
relationship are particularly at risk so
this we're asking a huge amount of the
public and I genuinely think the
transparency about what happens next and
the public will understand if there are
conditions and the public will
understand if we say you can't say
precisely what date or what time but
also those plans need to go into place
and also if we can get a consensus that
this is the right strategy going forward
I think that will get trust of the
public as well I'm secure can we turn
your attention just briefly to there to
the leaked report
to a legate into the investigation of
allegations of into anti-semitism and
within the party I mean trust things
first I spoke to the Shadow Chancellor
yesterday and she knew nothing about
this internal review of an internal
review that you yourself of announcer
why is the party reviewing a review that
it itself commissioned well there was a
leaked internal review that was leaked
yesterday or the day before when I saw
it I was concerned about it and
therefore set up an investigation into
how that came about and into the
contents of this internal review and how
it came to be leaked and that process
will now run through this is a report
into things that apparently happened
before I was leader of the Labour Party
we need an independent review it needs
to be speedy and professional but what I
said in my leadership campaign over
three months is that the Labour Party
needs to unite and focus on its historic
purpose which is Bingham government to
change millions of lives for the better
so if I pursue this I want to unite and
focus on that objective
indeed sorry for interrupting and we
have a problem with the delay on these
lines so thank you for being with me
with respect it doesn't sound as if you
have a huge amount of confidence in
again the findings of an internal
inquiry commissioned and set up by
comrades of yours within the party
carried out by comrades of yours in the
party in fact it rather suggests that
you've had a look at the findings of
this report and disagreed with them no I
haven't said that
what I've said is there needs to be an
independent investigation into the
report and the contents I will wait
until the end of that investigation
before commenting further because I
don't want to get too into this debate
about jumping to conclusions one way or
the other it needs to be looked at it
caused me serious cause for concern in
what I read so I want this investigation
I want it done speedily and
professionally but more than anything I
want our party to pull together and
focus on the real objective which is our
historic purpose the reason the Labour
Party was set up which is to go into
government and change millions of lives
for the better
are you prepared to eject people from
the party who were actively undermining
your predecessor general Cornyn I'm not
going to preempts the outcome of this
investigation I've set it up I want it
to be speedy and I'll obviously look at
the result when we get it but I'm not
gonna pre Empire sakae ozawa thanks very
much for joining us this morning hope
you and yours stay very well